this is the endless galaxy once home to
an ancient civilization known as the
endless who rose and fell eons ago all
that remains of them are mystical ruins
powerful artifacts and a mysterious near
magical substance known as dust after
centuries of evolution and scientific
progress your civilization has finally
uncovered Star Lanes
the cosmic strings that connect
planetary systems and form
constellations but more importantly you
now have the technology to use these
Star Lanes giving you a means of
reaching stars beyond your own traveling
faster than light your first exploration
ship is now ready orbiting your home
planet awaiting your orders as the
leader of your people you can choose to
proceed with caution sending probes into
the void or you can take risks gambling
your only ship on a star lane that leads
into the unknown while exploring you
will encounter many types of planetary
curiosities such as unknown signals
ruins resources and unexpected alien
life-forms
you can investigate these curiosities by
launching probes from exploration ships
but be wary of what you might find there
may be hazards as well as riches the
greatest of which are new civilizations
to court or to conquer
once you have fully explored the Stars
connected to your home system you will
need to send probes outward to locate
new constellations you will then have to
research warp drive technology so that
your ships can cross the void and
discover new solar systems new
curiosities and unveil the secrets that
they can see
[Music]
time will tell what events and
discoveries might lead to the knowledge
you seek and what great powers might be
disturbed for there are forces beyond
science that have shaped the history of
the galaxy and that might shape your
future as well
[Music]
you